[Music]
In Lebanon, he's known as the
White Wolf. His name is Michel
Efteriades. He's the owner of Musicall,
one of the hotspots of
Beirut's nightlife. He's also a producer,
businessman, political agitator—a
mysterious but also very
influential figure. An encounter with the master of
Lebanese nightlife. He has
a story, like many men,
men characterized like this
have a life behind them. In
Michel's case, he has lived a life. He has
always been a resister; he even
fought. He wasn't always on the
winning side, but he
was a resister. Every time someone
talks to me about Lebanon, I ask about
this phenomenon,
Efteriades, to find out what's become of him.
So, I've written this tribute to the activist, the
grassroots activist he was, the musician, the
writer, the man who loved the fine arts,
especially painting. But I also believe he's more than that,
and that
certainly in the Lebanon of tomorrow,
he should occupy a larger place.
I think
Michel Efteriades is one of those
people who, if he  They didn't exist, they would have to be invented.
I would say of him
that he is truly a cosmopolitan
in the noblest sense of the term, an
internationalist who has had enough of
these divisions of
humanity. Hello Thinkerview, I'm answering
your questions from my lounge,
Leutopiano, in the heart of Beirut, the
capital of
Lebanon. We can no longer talk about the weight
of French diplomatic influence in the
Middle East; it no longer exists. It's
American influence. They have become
spokespeople for American influence. They have become
tiny
pawns, pilot fish,
navigating with the big shark in search of
crumbs. It's truly
pathetic. France
had a major role in this region of the
world.
French diplomacy had
its moment of glory; it was a
benchmark in world diplomacy.
Now, as
my friend Jacques Vergess used to say, they've become the
Americans' [ __ ]. What happened in Syria
recently was a great
humiliation for the United States and its
allies. I don't know how they will be
able to justify it.  All this
excitement, these preparations to
go to war, and then overnight,
after the Russian bear
showed its teeth, they suddenly became,
in Sagi, suddenly, big shots,
people who
talk about dialogue, who
want a peaceful solution to
the crisis in Syria. So I don't know how, how can France
be credible after such a
turnaround?
France's foreign policy is
a
mercenary policy. France can no longer live
like in the colonial era. It no
longer has colonies that
allow it to live in
opulence. The French should
work more, they should respect
investors, they should create a
system that respects ambitious people. When
we talk about the length of the day for the little guy,
talking about coffee, going
out, dinner, all the culture of the
little guy, we can't
demand the big guy and want to live
like nababas.
Now they're trying
neocolonialism. Instead of going to
war themselves, they send
rusty weapons to proxies, to mercenaries
who fight the war in their place.
Hoping that once these
mercenaries are in power, they will be able to
secure contracts to
rebuild the country, to exploit its
natural resources—that's what they did
a bit with
Libya. They thought that this
system, this best practice, could be
applied elsewhere. But
Syria isn't Libya. What might
be valid in a country where
the army is
n't a real army ca
n't be applied in countries with
real armies, with people who are
better at analyzing what's happening.
They
can do it once or twice, but the
third or fourth time, it becomes a bit
difficult to get away with it,
even if
Bernard-Henri Lévy, the clown,
makes incredible pronouncements on
international channels
explaining that Bashar al-Assad is a
dangerous Islamist, even if he makes
grand speeches about the values ​​of...  His
daughter, a humanist philosopher, is no longer
credible; he is
completely finished, and it's a shame that
France, which still has great
philosophers today and which has had
philosophers who have
changed the history of
humanity,
accepts that someone like Bernard-
Henri Lévy can still appear on
international channels with "
French philosopher" underneath. That's a
disgrace to the history of
French philosophy and to
French culture in
general. I am
against
imperialism, which stems from
superpowers; Russia is one example. But
when I compare the current situation to
the situation of
American unipolarity that we experienced for the
last 20-30 years, I prefer to
have a strong Russia with a new
leader, someone who has
imposed their will. This limits the
damage. Absolute power is
absolutely corrupt. The United States had
become very
arrogant because it knew it
could
go wherever it wanted without ever having to answer to anyone, that it
make whatever mistakes it wanted.  that they can
do without being punished,
and that's very dangerous because
millions of deaths are called
collateral damage. So for them, it's just a
name, it's collateral damage, it's not much,
but for us who
live in this region of the world, it's
our families, it's our friends, it's
entire lives that are being crushed. And they did it, they did it repeatedly.
They wanted to continue doing it
until Russia and
Putin came and told them no. Putin
is a great leader.
The world hasn't known truly
great leaders for a long time. France had
a tradition of
highly cultured heads of state who had charisma,
talent, and
style, but now it's
really just mediocre ones. We've had
two mediocre ones, not just one, but the
French have had... I feel a bit
French in a way, since my culture
and my reading are French. It's
sad, it's sad that
France isn't its own.  Putin, who
could somewhat restore
France's image, it's sad to see a
French head of state who doesn't know how to
walk on a carpet
and who needs a woman to put him back on
the right track. It's sad to see a
French leader who seems like
nothing, who hasn't even
understood that there was an agreement being
signed between
the Russians and the Americans, and who,
even when the Americans
recalled their Serb, was
still there in Boyer, still all worked up.
It's truly sad for
France, and I say this out of love for France.
We can't speak of a
unified perception in the
region. When a Russian decision is
applauded by one part of the
Middle Eastern population, there's another part
that curses it, and vice versa. There are
currently two axes: a
Russian-Chinese-
Iranian axis, several parts of
Latin America, and in the region, there are people
who adhere to this axis.  The other
axis, where we have the United States, Israel, France,
England, countries like that, so
everywhere in the world there is
a strong divide between these two
axes and their supporters.
Under the pretext of
democracy, the West is
arming and supporting
barbaric hordes who practice cannibalism, who engage in
medieval behaviors, sometimes even more
ancient ones,
things like warfare, fire, and
beheading. In
Syria, they are
applying what they call
Sharia, which has nothing to do with
true Islamic Sharia. These are
sick people who come from all over the world
to
destroy a magnificent civilization that
has survived many invasions and reached
us intact. I'm talking about
villages like Maloua, where Aramaic, the
true language of Christ, is still
spoken. And these people will, in a few
months, destroy this
heritage
supported by the West under the pretext of democracy.
We are told about
democracy, about establishing a
democracy in Syria, while...  They
are allied with Saudi Arabia,
Qatar, and many other countries that have
nothing to do with democracy. Syria
wasn't paradise; Syria isn't
Sweden, or Assad's regime, but at least it was
a country where women had rights,
where minorities could
live well—religious,
sexual, and other minorities—where there was a
middle class, where you could talk about
politics a little. You don't have the
right to insult the president, but there are
many countries, democracies, and
great countries with a strong culture
of tolerance and freedom of speech
that don't tolerate
insulting heads of state. So it wasn't
really Syria; it wasn't the
despotism we're trying to
portray it as now. And even if it had been,
we can't, under the pretext
of overthrowing a regime that isn't
very
democratic, ally ourselves with
savages, with people like we
see now in Syria.
I am against it.  Intervention against
all
interventions. I think that a country,
a people who cannot
liberate themselves, a people who cannot
make their own
revolution, does not deserve to be
helped. A people who do not know how to
respect themselves, a line forming up.
When you go to Syria, to many
Arab countries, you see that, okay, they line up,
but it's
horizontal, the
line instead of vertical.
That is to say, we must begin
by educating the people before
giving them the right to vote.
I've been saying for years that if tomorrow there are
elections in the Arab world, it will be
the Islamists who take
power. We must begin by helping the
people through culture. Culture
is paramount. What prepares the
people is, uh, it's philosophers, it's
writers, uh, it's
intellectuals
who can create in the people
a consciousness, who can instill a
consciousness that prepares revolutions. In
revolutions in this part
of the world, those who
will vote, they will listen.
The word of the
Cher, and even for the
Christians of our region, is also
the word of the priest. But the priest and
the pulpit have never led very
far; it is the philosophers, it is
people who have a greater
open-mindedness, who can
lead people towards
Scandinavian or European-style democracies, or
democracies where there is respect
for the individual, respect for the
diversity of others. But if it's the
word of the Cher and the word of the priest, then hello!
The new Constitution, in
my opinion, means more
direct Western intervention in
Syria. And even back when I was very close
friends with people from the United Nations,
very high-ranking people, I was in a
debate where they wanted to know whether
or not to evacuate to Lebanon because there were
all these preparations for
American war, and I insisted and I took a stand
with them.  That there will be no
American strike,
nobody, nobody can tolerate that, no
Western leader can take the
risk now of
triggering a third
world war. I know the Russians well, I
lived there for a while, and I know
that when a Russian president says no, it means no, it's not "
we'll see" or "
maybe," and so they can't do it. The
consequences would have been
disastrous, we already saw the
result in Iraq. In Syria, it was even
worse, and not just Syria. When I
say Syria, it could have been
Lebanon too, and it would have set the whole
region ablaze. So I think we
avoided the worst. I hope that in Syria it won't
be a
long-term war, what we call a low-
intensity conflict, which can last a very
long time. It's not a real
war, but it's
Mad Max gangs moving around, spreading
terror, burning villages, raping, cutting down
trees, doing
crazy things, and they are very
difficult to eliminate because
they keep going.  Coming soon, they come from
all over the Arab and
Muslim world, and it's an
unlimited reservoir. It
could be useful for several countries to send all this
stock of
potential terrorists to the butcher, but it costs Syria
and Lebanon a great deal, and
all the countries in the
region too. I hope Russia will be able to
assert that it has enough leverage to exert
pressure and stop this madness
in Syria. I think Assad cannot
return to the
state, to the legitimacy he had
before the events in Syria. He will have to
make concessions. That's the
case in all negotiations; in all
negotiations, both sides
are called upon to make small
concessions. And I think that by making
small concessions and finding
a kind of scenario, new
pacts, they can rebuild
Syria. There are people to exclude, those who
destroyed their country and who were
mercenaries in the pay of the
monarchies of the Gulf or the
powers.
Foreigners don't have a place in
the new country. It will
take time, but I'm rather
optimistic.
The influx of Syrian refugees into Lebanon
is a real catastrophe for Lebanon.
A population of
3.5 million
Lebanese cannot
accommodate 2 million refugees. It's a very
small country, barely a
French department, and suddenly 2
million destitute refugees
arrive in this department. It's
inconceivable; it's a catastrophe that no
other country could have
absorbed. There's this
Lebanese miracle aspect, this strength, this resilience of the
Lebanese, this capacity to absorb
shocks, but we mustn't exaggerate.
The whole world, especially those who
consider themselves friends of the
Syrian people and those who want what's
best for Syria, must address this
problem and come to the aid of these
refugees through
Lebanon, because it's we who are
paying the price with our
economy, with our well-being. We've
already paid enough; we've had 15 years.
Syria took part in
this civil war against the Lebanese,
so when things are going well
for them, it's the
Syrian army that invades Lebanon, and when
they have problems, it's the
Syrian refugees who come to invade us. So
the discourse may seem a bit
nationalistic; it
may disturb the snobs of
good intentions and humanitarianism,
of what should and should
n't be
done. But I'm being
realistic.
I like my brother, but if he
comes with his whole family to my
house and wants to sleep in my bed
and ruin my life,
I tell him no. There are
limits. A guest, a refugee, should
be a little
more discreet, a little less
intrusive. There's no need to
arrive with the two or three cars of
the family. There's no need to
drive around because we have
monstrous traffic jams. We're a service-oriented country; we do
n't have countryside with farmers
who are struggling.  Cultivating it
helps our economy. We don't have a
large industry; we're
service-based. We can no longer have a meeting,
we can no longer send a document, or get someone from
one place to another. We can't
do anything anymore. The simplest trip, which used to
take two or three minutes, now takes an
hour. So it's a truly
alarming situation. And the problem is that
every time I talk about it, there's an
uproar and
[Music]
insults. I have very good
relations with the Lebanese army. Right here,
every week I
meet dozens of officers.
I think that
Lebanon's hope lies with the Lebanese army,
that the Lebanese army can
truly make a difference for
Lebanon. In such a rotten country, where there's so much
corruption, so many
communities, so many different communities,
the army can play a major role.
I launched a campaign to support
the Lebanese army. I asked that
the army  If the Lebanese take power, well,
I'm not saying it's out of love for
the army in general. It's not a
dogmatic approach; it's realistic. It's
also a bit selfish because
I know
my own interests and the interests of the
Lebanese people. The Lebanese army is the only one
that can guarantee
Lebanon's survival with all the conflicts
surrounding it. It's a small country that
can be easily controlled,
run like a fortress. You could
call that a coup d'état, but there's
a form of coup d'état that's more widely
accepted: the
guardian coup. This is when
officers take power not out of
love for power or for their
own interests, but because they want to protect
this country, because they want to be the
guardians of this heritage, of what
our parents left us, to
pass it on to future generations—maybe
not generations, but in 10
years. That is to say, to protect the country, to
work on the institutions, to prepare
a new
generation of people through a
new culture, a new approach.
Imposing a common
history book, calming the clergy—Muslims,
Christians, indeed all
forms of clergy—limiting the actions
of religious figures, and
preparing a new country—it will take as long as
necessary, and the army will return
the country to the people.
The media must also be calmed because freedom
of expression is good, but it does
n't give the right to say just anything. There are
limits. Yet the
Lebanese, and many in Arab countries,
think that freedom of expression means
the right to insult, the
right to proselytize, to engage in
racial incitement, to incite religious hatred. But no,
the army must take power; the army
must be able to control everything if we want
Lebanon to continue to exist. The
nourishing project is a cultural,
social, political,
philosophical, and other kind of project. It's a project
that offers solutions to many problems, problems that are currently being addressed
without
solutions, with
easy solutions. It's an idea that, of
course, may seem
utopian, and indeed is currently a utopia,
but I think that all progress...  Throughout
human history, everything began as
a utopia, and
humanity's greatest strides were the realization
of these utopias. It's
becoming increasingly easy
now to communicate a new
project; the time for Noristan has
truly come. There are many people
disgusted by
politicians and the way the world
is run, and they believe that we can
now dream and work towards the
realization of a project like
Noristan. So it could have many
names, but I chose this name because it has a fun, playful side.
And I think it's quite good to
present a very serious, solid idea,
but with a lighter, more approachable package. That's
much better than doing what
other politicians do, which is to
serve up rubbish
in a very serious package. So it's better to
attract young people, not to
do something completely
impenetrable, to present
complex,
serious ideas—ideas that stem from a
lot of experience and
philosophy—in a simple, not simplistic, way, rather than doing what
other politicians do. I mean, I
sometimes see speeches by politicians
where they speak, they
present very well, they know how to
speak very well, they've
learned, uh, the language, the body
language, from specialists, and
they're very well dressed, but they
say just anything. That is to say, when
you analyze, when you take a closer look at what they
said and read
the content, it
really doesn't mean anything. And this thing in
presidential debates where it's...  It's
becoming ridiculous because it's a
competition to see who has the best memory.
2.34% of people think that, and the UT says
no, it's 2.36%, but we don't care about any of that. These are
details that make no
sense because now I
go on my computer, I type into
Google, I google any
statistic, I find everything. I don't
need a parrot coming to
repeat it to me on TV. I don't
need to read about someone who has a
good memory or someone
who doesn't know. I need people who
provide solutions. But all these
people, all these great leaders, from
European parties and their
heads of state, bring nothing,
absolutely nothing. And that's why there's a
kind of "our future" among
young people, among European youth. They're
misled. They're 20 years old and
they're there
[Music]
thinking about the percentage, I don't really know what, that
they  They'll be retired in
40 years, and they're out there protesting
over petty things, but that's not what's
going to change the world, that's not what's going to
change people's lives.
People need to realize that they
can demand big
change. Obama's campaign
was all about change, but it was nothing,
minimal changes, it's all the same old story. It's
exactly the same policies
he's continuing to pursue, but under
slogans that are supposedly smarter because
he's smarter than the
cowboy who came before him. It's
hard to be dumber than George W.
Bush,
so just because he's a little
smarter doesn't mean we should be
ecstatic or that Americans should be
satisfied with such a change. Just
because he's a little darker-skinned
than the Yang who came before him doesn't mean
we should say it's the
victory
of Martin Luther
King's dream. It wasn't that.  What Martin
Luther King was talking about isn't about taking a
Black man and putting him there. He's not even a Black
American; he's a mixed-race
African American who became
president. That's not a victory
for Black people. When you look at
American cities now, you can still
see the misery that the
Black population, the descendants
of slaves, live in. When you see the
number of white billionaires and
millionaires there are and the
number of Black billionaires, you see the
difference that exists and that continues. That's not what
has changed. So we
must demand
change, real change. What has changed is what
Americans have changed.
And what happens
very often in changes of
head of state or when we switch
from one party to another is that we
only change the screen. But the
viruses, because what we see on
a computer is the screen, the virus is
n't on the computer screen
when we keep the hard drive, when we
keep the same environment.  And if we
change the screen, we haven't done anything. We need
a
radical change. I can't live, I can't
imagine my life without a
noble fight. Living to eat, drink, and [ __ ] isn't
a life for me. It's not okay.
Pleasures in
life are important, but I need
a noble mission. I need a
grand project to keep fighting, to
keep
appreciating, to keep appreciating
being on this earth. So, I
need a project like the Nooristant,
even if its completion doesn't go as planned. I won't
see the project completed, but at
least I have the pleasure of telling myself,
every time I'm a little depressed,
every time I'm verbally attacked by
people or receive
insults from my haters, when I
feel threatened, that it's worth it. I
'm doing something,
putting a train on the tracks, and this
train can lead
humanity towards something beautiful,
towards a brighter tomorrow, towards a
better world. And I'm
convinced of this project.  It's not a
vision I had, it wasn't an archangel
who came to visit me at night, it was
n't voices I heard. It's based
on personal experience, a struggle
that began 30 years ago when
I was 15. It's suffering,
the suffering of losing friends, of seeing
friends fall before me. It's
years of exile. It's
the sum of all that that
allowed me to
develop the philosophy and system of
Noistan. I know it will bring
great benefits to
all of humanity. And with
globalization, we can no longer
talk about the well-being of one part of
humanity and not another because it
will generate jealousy. Travel is
very easy; the internet is there to make
bombs. And so, if there isn't a
distribution of wealth, if there isn't
a distribution of happiness and well-being,
the poor will one
day come to visit the rich.
Money doesn't go to the poor;
the poor go to the money. In
disadvantaged neighborhoods, if they're hungry, they go out
and come to the wealthy neighborhoods
to break down the door and open the
refrigerator. And this is on a
global scale. Before, people were starving, they didn't know
how to
live, how
others lived. But now, in the most remote favela,
in the most remote
working-class neighborhood of an
Arab country, they have satellites. They
can see what
others have access to and what they don't. There will always be
rich and poor, but it won't be due
to birth. It's not like winning the lottery or winning a plane ticket.
When you're in
Switzerland now, even if you're
stupid and lazy, you know you'll
live better than a genius who was in
some African countries or in
disadvantaged countries. I have a message for the
French, not for the
French government. I think it's pointless to
talk to people who know perfectly well
that they're doing...  Bad things happen, but
they're
blinded by profit, by
financial interests, so it's pointless. You shouldn't
even try to
talk to these people; you have to
punish them, force them to change their policies.
Because we're debating with people who have
a different ideology, with people
who are in the wrong
because they haven't understood
things, but someone who knows, like a
mobster who knows what he's doing is
wrong, there's no point in telling him
no, he shouldn't do that. He already knows.
But it's a lost cause for the
French. I'm going to tell them not to get
lost in the
details and not to sacrifice
the whole for the smallest. So all their
debates and all these divisions that no longer make any
sense, like right and
left, because now when I
see someone—I don't follow
French politics very closely—but
now when I see a
French politician speak,
I really don't know anymore if he's right
or left, and yet we continue to
stick these labels on them. I see  Sometimes
now, speeches from people on the far
right that sound
really similar, but you might think they're communists, communists—
I see communists, that's the far
right—
so we need to stop thinking in those terms.
We need to rebuild
French politics, we need to rebuild
European politics, we need to rebuild
world politics. France has a place to occupy on
the world stage.
French culture is one of the greatest
cultures in the world: the French Renaissance, the
Age of Enlightenment. France's influence must not
cease.
France must return to what made it
great, to what made
French culture inspire so many revolutions around the
world. This is why this
culture has always been that of
revolutionaries, that of people who
want to develop secular
societies. Secularism is a
very important concept, and
France has a
leading role in promoting secularism.
This must be done through culture,
real culture, not the culture of
Bernard-Henri Lévy and
other clowns who are
the media darlings.  For
many reasons, it's
really, it's really sad when
I see what's
happening. I hope, I believe in
the strength of the French people, who
made one of the most beautiful
revolutions and who also
made other cultural revolutions. When
I see the spirit of
the writings, the
graffiti of May '68, when I see the
solidarity that France has
shown for
causes like the
Cuban Revolution or, in
Chile, the real September 11th,
I tell myself that it can't just disappear.
It's not that far away.
I think there's also a problem in
the French education system
because my children are in a
French high school, so when I
rarely see them because they don't live in Lebanon,
and I see what they're being taught,
I think it's
sad too that there are
things that
educators... when
educators...  Mistakes mean
entire generations are being
sacrificed. We need to go back to the old ways.
What
I'm about to say isn't very progressive for someone who's
always been progressive, but sometimes
good old methods are
being lost. A lot of
laxity has never created greatness.
Nothing in this world was created by lazy people, by
people who don't
want to get up early, who don't
want to fight, who don't
see the big picture.
[Music]
Long live the Revolution! A
little demonstration: we shouldn't
resort to weapons, it's the last
resort. It's not crap, it's not
something we should
do. We see in Washington, there's this
big drug problem, and there are
sociologists, doctors,
all sorts of experts who say that we
really need to change the law, and
especially, to start with, legalize
marijuana. But it's a taboo subject in
Washington. I'm the perfect
example, I think.  that there are
very few other examples of what
Canadians call
Bayons proceedings, meaning
you are bombarded with lawsuits and
even if you win, you
lose because the time you
spend defending yourself,
the world moves on, and there's a
kind of steamroller effect.
The revelations about the Prisme affair
are interesting for more than one reason, firstly
because we now have
irrefutable proof of this surveillance and
its massive and widespread nature.
For 10 years, we collected evidence and
testimonies.